what's up everybody this is john from
coding addict and welcome to a redux
toolkit tutorial video
as far as the elevator pitch for redux
toolkit essentially redux till kit is
good old redux just with batteries
included meaning unlike traditional
redux
all the useful packages are by default
part of redux toolkit
so instead of wasting our time
on annoying boilerplate setup we can
right away get to work
during the tutorial we're going to build
this card application and in the process
we'll see
all the cool features of redux toolkit
in action
so things like store slash reducers
action creators and of course
create a sync thunk
as far as the requirements if you have
not worked with redux before
my expectation
is that you are at least familiar
with use reducer hook
since they share a bunch of common terms
and syntax
and just in case
you need a refresher on user reducer
in the description of this video i'll
leave a link to my react tutorial video
where i cover use reducer
in great detail
if you prefer learning by building bunch
of cool projects and enjoy my teaching
style
you can find all my courses at
johnsmilk.com again the site you're
looking for is www.johnsmilk.com
in order to follow you will need a star
and you can find it in this github repo
so look for my profile
john smilga and the actual repo name is
redux toolkit tutorial again the name of
the repo
that you're looking for is redux
toolkit tutorial and once you get here
just pick the option that makes the most
sense to you
i think in my case i'm going to go for
download zip option
then
i want to crack it open
and in the folder you'll find two more
folders
the final as well as the starter and
needless to say that in the final one
you'll find the complete source code and
then in the starter is where we'll do
all of our work so let me take this
sucker out
let me open up
the text error visual studio code
i'll right away set it side by side now
this is a standard react application i
used create react app
the only difference is that i removed
some boilerplate code and i also added
some resources so in here what we want
to do is run npm install and also npm
start so npm install
and pm start
and there is an app so at the moment
notice there's only two we have some car
items which we'll use in the beginning
as our data and also a few icons
i'll discuss them a little bit later
index.css all our css and also of course
index js
so once you get the repo once you get
the star
install all dependencies run npm start
you should
see in the browser a heading 2 with i
believe it was
redux toolkit and if you do we're in
good shape and we can proceed to the
next step
in the starter you'll also find a readme
file
where i laid out all the steps we're
going to take as well as some useful
links and first if you want to find more
info about redux toolkit you can always
utilize this link so this one goes
directly to their docs
and we have a few ways that we can add
redux toolkit to our project first we
can go with straight up template
so in that case instead of going nbx
create react app and then the app name
we also add this hyphen hyphen and then
template and redux now from my
experience they add
way too much boilerplate so
essentially i always avoid that and in
general i just go with the redux toolkit
so i set up the application
let's say with create react app and then
install the
toolkit separately and we do that
with npm install and then add redux js
and then forward slash toolkit and also
we'll add react redux
and i'll talk about it in a second now
let me just quickly mention that if for
some reason
you get some issues when you just run
npx create react app and again it's not
specific to this template one if
something goes bananas with npx you can
always try to go with create react app
and then the latest one so this is just
a side note now back to the toolkit so
when we install
redux js toolkit we actually install
fuel libraries
so we installed the redux which is going
to be our core library we also install
emr which is going to allow us to mutate
the state
we install redux thunk
which will handle the async actions and
also we install reselect which will
simplify the reducer setup
so these things of course will only make
sense if you already have worked with
redux so this is already provided for us
and of course we'll see all of those
things in action and if you didn't work
with redux before don't worry
of course i'll explain all of them
and also as an extra we get right away
redux devtools and also combine reducers
right from the get-go again if you
haven't worked with redux i totally
understand if none of those things make
sense but don't worry we'll talk about
them later
now why we also install this package
the react redux well you see
redux can be used
with any front-end framework it's not
specific
to react
and in order to connect our application
to the redux this is where we'll use the
package by the name of react redux now
needless to say
that of course if you'll take a look at
the package.json
you will see the
both packages you'll see the toolkit as
well as the react redux but just so you
don't think that
there is some funny business going on
let me copy this line of code let me
install both packages
and once the install is complete we can
start setting up our redux store
so the install is done we go with npm
start and if we take a look at the
package.json you will find
the toolkit
as well as react redux and with this
inflation now we can start setting up
our application with redux toolkit okay
and once we have installed all
dependencies up next i want to set up
the store
and you can think of store
as the entire state for your application
so remember previously we used context
api now in this case we'll use toolkit
and we'll set up the store
and the syntax is following where first
we want to create store.js
somewhere in the source
we want to import configure store
function from the toolkit and yes in
order to speed this up i'll just
reference it i still could please keep
in mind that of course i'm talking about
the redux token
and then in this function
we want to pass in the object
and in the object there's going to be a
reducer property
which is going to be object itself
and then in here we'll set up our
features
and i fully understand that
i mean this
can look somewhat fuzzy don't worry as
we start setting up the features you'll
see everything in action so for the time
being just bear with me
and then once we have the store we want
to export that and this is the case
where you can export this as default
so the difference of course is just
export default and then the store
or you can go with named export and then
we want to go back to
index.js we want to import
store
from the store file
as well as the provider
from react redux like i said this is the
library that connects redux store or
redux
to our application
and similarly to context api
we want to wrap
our entire application so we want to
grab this provider there's a store prop
and we just want to pass in the store
coming
from the store file
so let's get cracking first
i'm going to go with
store
js
in here let's import configure store
so import we're looking for
configure store notice right away i have
suggestion for that and then let's set
up that store like i said at the moment
it might look somewhat funky the moment
we'll set up some features it will make
sense so let's go here with const
and of course i'm adding export as well
bench store
that is equal to configure store let's
pass in the object let's set up the
reducer is an object itself and for time
being it's going to be empty and most
likely we'll get the warning in a
console don't worry about it again
all of this functionality is coming up
and then let's navigate to index.js
let's import both of the things let's go
with import
then store
and this is coming from the store file
of course and also we want to get that
provider so we import and then we're
looking for provider now that is coming
from react redux and now let's wrap our
entire application so let's say provider
here let's close it out let's wrap our
app
and then we want to set up a store prop
and we want to set it equal to our store
and if nothing breaks
we are heading in the right direction
so then we can set up the slice again
like i said
if you see this warning don't worry
we'll fix it in a second beautiful and
once we have the store in place now
let's set up the slice
and i fully understand that this name is
totally funky you're like what slice are
you talking about and i want you to
think of slush as the
feature of your application so if we
take a look at the complete project
you'll notice that yes we have the card
functionality
but we also have the modal
and you can think of it as two features
our application
so we have one feature for the model and
the second one
is going to be for our card
and of course
the bigger our application
the more features we're going to have
and in the redux toolkit land it is
called slice
now in order to set up slice a common
convention is to set up
features folder but of course naming is
always up to you
then whatever is going to be the name of
the feature so in my case it's going to
be card that's why i'll set up a cart
folder and then we want to set up a file
again like i keep mentioning the naming
is up to you but again typically you'll
go with whatever feature and then slice
js
now in there
you'll want to get create slice and
don't worry about this one that create
async thunk assign it i'll remove it
worry about that later
and then we want to invoke that function
create slash we want to give it a name
again it's totally up to you but in my
case i'm going to go with cart
and then we have initial state property
where we just set up
whatever state we want in my case i'll
set it up as a separate object and in
here i'm going to go with cart items
with an amount so how many items i have
in the cart what is the card total both
of them zero and then is loading true
because eventually we will load this
from the api then i'll log the sucker
the card slice
and there we'll have the reducer
and of course i'll talk about this one a
little bit later once we get there and
eventually what we want to do
is in the store
we want to import card reducer so that's
going to be the function
that controls this state in our slice so
think of our application we'll just
split up the functionality where this
slice is just responsible
for the cart
and this reducer specifically is going
to modify it whatever functionality we
set up
and then in that reducer that we set up
in the last video notice there's a
complaint that there's no valid reducer
now we want to set up a key now key name
is really up to you
just like everything else and i know
that you're probably sick of hearing
this but i just want to make this clear
where this is totally up to you you can
call this banana pudding if you want
just remember that later
once we start setting up our
functionality yes of course we'll have
to access this name so therefore i'm
going to go with cart and i want to set
it equal to reducer so the function that
we'll have access to
and a function that will allow us to
control this
piece of state
for this specific functionality
hopefully this is clear so now let's go
to source we want to create new folder
like i said common convention we'll call
this features so features our
application in our case cart and modal
then let's create another folder
and we're going to go here with cart
then inside of the cart let's go with
new file and we're going to go with cart
slice
js
so once we're here we want to import we
want to import and we'll say
create and slice
now for some reason it does not oh yep
it does
so i have the suggestion
and let's right away invoke it i'm going
to call this const
cart
and slice and that is equal to create
slice
it's a function we pass in the object
and here we can set up a bunch of
properties
so first we want to set up the name
so i'm going to go here with card
then we want to go with that initial
state this is the case since i have more
properties we might as well set it up as
a separate object so let's set up here
initial state
and then we'll add card items which
initially is going to be empty array but
then we'll take a look at multiple
approaches the local data and then the
data coming from the api i also want to
go with amount
so how many items i have in the cart and
please be aware that i'm not just
talking about the products i have
in my cart i'm actually
looking for the item count
so how many items of that specific
product i have and this is going to be
that amount hopefully that is clear then
we want to go with total so total money
both of them zero initially and then is
loading because eventually we'll pull
this from the api so that's going to be
our initial state once we save notice
right away
initial state in here references the
initial property then we want to log
this sucker
and we want to quickly
import install js now in a second we'll
do more proper setup i just want to
showcase what we have in the cart slice
so let me save it then i'll navigate
back to the store and for time being
let's just import the entire file like i
said more proper setup is coming let's
just go here
with the features
then cart and then cart slice and once
we import of course we right away
invoke the file
and here we'll see that console log
so
we'll have some actions here something
that we'll discuss a little bit later
once we set up some reducers we have
case reducers again something we don't
need to worry about right now get
initial state again a function that gets
the state name and then notice all the
way in the bottom we have that reducer
so this reducer
is the one that is going to control
that
state in this slice
and that's why we want to export that we
want to export this and in the store we
want to come up with a key
and set it equal to that reducer so
let's try this out i'm going to go with
cart then instead of just getting the
file i'll actually look for that reducer
but i'll set it up as a default one
so for time being i'll comment this one
out we'll come back to this one because
again we'll talk about these actions
eventually
and now i just want to export that
reducer now there's million ways how we
can export this in this case i'm going
to go export default and then cart slice
dot reducer again this is an object and
this is a property so let's export this
then in the store we want to import
so i'm going to go with cart not slice
but reducer again if you wanna name this
differently of course you can and then
we're going with from and now we'll go
with cart equals to
cart reducer and we shouldn't see any
error messages anymore because now we
have the proper setup
so now we can take a look how we can
access the data first from that initial
state and then of course eventually
we'll also take a look at how we can set
up functionality to control this but our
first step
is going to be accessing this data okay
and before we go any further let's also
quickly install redux devtools
and the good news is that as far as the
code
we don't need to add any configuration
basically the moment we install redux
toolkit we're good to go however when it
comes to browser we do need to install
extra extension
and the extension needle was this one
redux devtools and in the chrome if you
want to install extension just go to
your extensions
and then more specifically look for open
chrome web store
and then in here
look for the redux one not 3x4k
redux so this is the extension you're
looking for
and once you do that let me open this up
in the big browser so that's my
localhost 3000
you'll notice a tab
a redux tab
and here we'll be able to find bunch of
useful info
now at the moment
i mean we have a clean application we
only have the state but yes eventually
once we set up the reducers the actions
and all that yes this is going to be a
very useful
tool
now at the moment the only thing that i
want to showcase that this is our state
notice that's my card card items amount
total and is loading and yes
of course
in our store
once we add
more reducers
all of them will meet over here and
that's why this tool is very useful
because as we'll dispatch our actions
we'll clearly see how our state changes
beautiful and once we have set up
the redux devtools up next let's see how
we can access that initial state in any
of the components
so we have the initial
state in the slice
and let's say that i want to set up a
navbar component where i want to access
the amount
and the setup is following where we do
want to create the components folder
then navbar.s
and there we'll import cart icon so
that's the component that's coming from
the icons folder
and i'll discuss how we can
set up the component in the following
video because at the moment i do want to
focus
on the state value axis
and then we want to import use selector
so that's a hook coming from react redux
and then in the navbar component before
the return we want to invoke use
selector
and the selector is looking for one
thing it's looking for the function
and as a parameter we get access to the
entire state
so we're talking about the entire store
again
in our case we just have the cart but
eventually
we'll add more reducers over here so
since this is a parameter of course we
can call it whatever we want
so you'll see probably state but
actually my preference is to call this a
store because that signals to me that
that is entire store so the entire state
of my application and then more
specifically i'm looking for dot cart
why
because that's the name of the property
over here and then in initial state if
you remember we do have the amount
property and of course there's million
ways how we can set this up for example
we can just return from this function
this amount or
since in this case we're returning the
entire object we can destructure it
so let's try to set this up
where in the source i want to create a
new folder i'm going to call this
components over here
then let's set up that now bar
now bar
js
in here
like i said first let's import cart icon
something i'm going to discuss
in the following video then we also want
to get that u selector
so let's say use
selector hook that is coming from react
redux and now let's set up that
navbar component
so i'm going to use my extension i'll
set up the navbar and first let's set up
the return
and then we'll worry about the actual
state so let's say here nav
i do want to add here a div
so inside of the div let's go or i'm
sorry inside of the nav let's go there
let's add a class name
of nav
center
and here we want to go with heading 3
redux toolkit
and after that let's save it and we
don't see anything so let me refresh
don't see anything in the browser and of
course the reason for that is because i
didn't import in the app.js so let me go
back
and in the app.js let's import the
navbar
and then let's set it up over here
so what i want to do
as far as the return in app.js
i just want to go with main
and then the number so instead of the
heading two
redux toolkit
we'll go with main tags
and then first we'll set up the navbar
and then
we'll set up the rest of the card items
as well so that
should be
our navbar okay that's awesome
and as far as the other stuff
i think i'm going to go here
with a card icon but that is going to be
placed in the nav container
so
right after this heading 3 i'm going to
go with div the class of
nav container
and in here let's set up that cart icon
yep that is how it's going to look like
and then let's go with dave with the
class of amount
container
and then paragraph
with a class of total
total hyphen
and amount and at the moment let's just
place zero here let's save this and now
let's see how we can access
the entire
state of our application
so first let's just log the sucker let's
say use selector
so that's the hook and like i said it's
looking for one parameter which is going
to be our function
and then inside of this function as a
parameter we get that entire store so
for time being i'm going to call this
store and i'll log it i'll say that the
only thing that i want to do in this
function is log the store and what
you'll notice in the console
is
our entire state which is just awesome
if you ask me so take a look over here
we have card items we have amount and we
have the total
so again i know i'm repeating myself
but essentially the idea is that
using this use selector notice how we
don't need to pass anything coming from
the specific slice or nothing like that
we can right away in this function
access our entire store
and essentially what we want to do
we want to
return something whether that is
specific
property for example amount
or
of course you can return the entire cart
and then you can the structure so first
let's just set it up where
we return the amount so notice over here
we have undefined in line five because
we're not returning anything from this
function yet
and let's set up over here in the
paragraph and then we'll take a look at
the
the structuring option as well i don't
think i'm going to leave this for your
reference because again
we'll set up multiple ways anyway so
first let's go with amount and that one
is equal to
let's again invoke use selector let's
pass in the function
and i'm going to be setting up the arrow
function and i'll go right away with
implicit return so again in here we're
accessing the entire state of our
application and we go with store
cart because that's the property value
and yes
once we add more reducers
in our store then of course we'll be
able to access it so i'm going to go
here let's say with modal
and i'm not going to pass anything in
because i do need to set up the reducer
then of course we'll be able to access
with
store dot model hopefully that is clear
and this is very very useful because
again we don't need to import anything
specific from that slice we have access
to entire store and then let's go with
amount so this is what i'm returning
from the function
and probably it's not going to be
surprising
if i pass here the value still going to
be zero now let's test this out though
let's go to our features slice and let's
change this around let's say that
there's going to be five items the one
when i save notice
now of course i have this value of five
so we know that our functionality works
and like i said
there's million different ways how we
can set this up
and one of them
is actually destructuring so i know that
i can return store.cart
which is essentially
a object correct and then inside of it i
have the amount property so this is also
valid
under value did not change and we didn't
get any bugs so that's how we can access
data
from our slice
we need to pick the component we need to
use a use selector in here we pass in
the function
and as a parameter this function gets
the entire store
and then we just need to pick what we
want to return in my case i want to
return
cart from this function it is an object
and it represents
this initial state and more specifically
i'm looking for the amount that's why i
destructure it and then i display it
here in the return as far as the icons
in this project i decided to go
different route
where i use the hero icons site
so once you navigate there
you'll notice a bunch of nice icons and
essentially i just set them up as
components so let me show you with one
and then you'll understand the general
concept just pick the icon you want in
this case i think i'm gonna go with this
band one
and as far as i noticed there's really
no difference whether you go with jsx or
svg
so let me just copy this one
let's navigate back and then in the
icons you'll notice full-blown
components that i right away export so
let me keep scrolling and i'm going to
call this testing so i'm going to say
export const and that's going to be my
testing component
and in here you just want to set up the
value you want to return
so this essentially will be the icon now
i am styling it though in the css and in
a second you'll see what i mean
so i have this testing icon right now so
that's the return that i just copied
so now let's navigate to the navbar
since i already have the import for the
card icon
and let's set up over here the testing
one as well
and we can place it anywhere we want so
let me put it side by side and you'll
notice that this is a giant ore i'm
sorry well i already applied the styling
so
maybe
this is not going to work over here
maybe let me set up here
the
fragment and then you'll see what i mean
so let me move the sucker down again
this is just temporary you don't have to
follow along
but you'll notice that if we don't apply
the styling we'll get this massive
icon basically that's the default that
they provide
so in the styles in the index.css
i added some styling for specific icons
so now i'm talking about the cart icon
and also the same applies
for these ones or here as well
so not only you'll need to get the icon
but notice over here i applied some
width as well as the color and of course
you can add more style so essentially
that's how i set
up my icons where i created icons js
and in here you'll find three icons
so one for the cart and then the other
ones for the actual cart items
and then i imported the icon from the
hero icon so i set it up as a component
i export
and then i import in any of the
components that i want
and then i just need to apply a little
bit of styling and you want to target
the svg so now let me remove the testing
one
and also let me remove it from the icon
since we won't use it
and now let's proceed to the next step
all right and up next let's work on our
car atoms so at the moment it is empty
array or
i did prepare
an array of products just so we can set
up the initial functionality yes
eventually we'll fetch this data from my
api
and in a process will practice of how we
can set up asynchronous operations in
redux toolkit but for time being this
will be hard coded data and it is
located in the card items and as you can
see it is an array where each item is an
object with some properties so what
we're going to do
we're going to
set up the initial state equal to that
array so of course we just need to
import and then we'll repeat the same
steps
like we did
with an amount
in number however
since we have an array we'll have to
iterate over and all of that cool stuff
so first what i want to do
is go to the cart slash and we want to
import we want to import
those card items so
let's go here with card items it is a
default export so it doesn't really
matter how we call it here
and then we need to go two levels up
we're looking for the card items
and in here
where we have the initial state let's
set up card items equal to current items
now if we want to see that we can either
go to the nav bar
since in there we have the use selector
and we can of course log it or
we can take an advantage of the redux
devtool so let's navigate here
let's refresh just so we're on the safe
side if we navigate to the redux tab
tools now what you'll notice that
card items in the card
is an actual array and like i said each
object represents that item with a bunch
of useful properties so our next step
is going to be
setting this up in the app.js where
we'll grab them we'll iterate over and
then for each item we'll return a
component
with the image the title and rest of the
stuff
not bad not bad
so we set up the card items
equal to an actual array instead of an
empty one
now let's set up two more components the
card container just
and cart
item js
and just to showcase so this is going to
be the container where we'll have
all of the items as well as the total
and the clear card functionality now
eventually we'll add the model but the
idea won't change
if we click on clear cart then of course
we'll have md card
and then we also want to set up that
cart item
where again we'll display
all of this info
and yes we'll practice on use selector
again
we're in the cart container we not only
want to get the car items we also want
to get the total
as well as the amount because we'll use
that amount
to display some things conditionally in
this case if the amount is less than one
then i'll display this and then
if there are some items in a card then
of course there's going to be a
different logic and in the card item
we'll just pass in the id as a key as
well as the
properties of the atom and then we'll
destructure it now when it comes to card
item for the most part we'll get there
our action creators which of course will
set up a little bit later so for now we
just want to worry about
rendering the card
items on the screen
so let's get cracking where i want to go
two components and let's go here with
cart
container
and i also want to set up that
cart item js now when it comes to car
animal work on now on in next video
for a moment and as you know shoot me
card items should be card item one
and now let me fix this one as well
where i'm gonna go with cart item
now we wanna import that in the cart
container
so let's set up this component as well
so r a f c e
and let's right away import that card
item
so let's go here with cart item then we
want to navigate to the app.js
and we also want to get
that card container so let's get that
one and i'll place it right after the
container meaning the navbar sorry
and we should see on the screen cart
container awesome
now what's next well let's take a look
at the readme
where we do have the card item we also
want to get the huge selector and now
from my application state
i want to get the entire card and i'll
just destructure
car amps total
as well as the amount like i said the
amount we'll use to display
conditionally
empty cart
and again i already showcased that but
let me show you one more time this is
what we want to set up if the card
is empty and we'll control that with the
amount now if there are some values in
the cart then this is what we want to
return we want to go with section header
iterate over card items
and then also in the footer
we want to display the total with
the clear cart button
so let's set this one up
where i'm going to go with import then
huge selector from react redux let's
right away access all of the items so
let's say here const
we're looking for
cart
and items
total
also we want to get the amount and all
of that is equal to
use
selector let's pass in the function and
what we want to return we want to go
here with store or state however you
want to call it
store and then cart so we get all of
those values
right away let's set up that condition
where i'll say amount is less than one
if that is the case what we want to
return well we want to go here with
section
then let's add a class name of cart
and let's set up some logic over here
let's say here
header
and inside of the header we'll have a
heading 2
your
bag and then right after that let's go
with heading 4
and we'll say empty card now we do need
to add here empty
card class
and let's add a text your card is
currently empty or your bag
is empty let's save it now since the
amount is zero this is exactly what we
display
so in order to see the atoms of course
we'll have to navigate back to the card
slice and again for time being we'll
just hard code this don't worry
eventually we'll set up some action
creators
that control this logic essentially
we'll set up some reducers
and by default redux toolkit is going to
give us those action creators so let's
go back to the cart container
and right after this one we want to set
up another return
so
as you saw this one was
if we have less than one and now since
we hard coded we have four
so in here we want to go with another
return
another section
and we do want a class so class will be
equal to cart
and
then the same deal we want to set up
that header
so header over here
and
inside of it we're just going to go with
heading 2 your bag
your bag let's save that one and yeah
let's say no this is wrong so it should
be class name
then we want to iterate over
the card items
so for time being we just want to set up
a div
then we want to grab those card items we
want to run the map
and this is the actual array correct and
then for every item we want to return
that card item that we just
set up
and we want to pass in the data now on a
screen we'll just see that text whatever
we have over there and here we have the
caram but eventually yes we'll access it
and we'll correctly display it so we're
mapping over i'll call this item so now
i'm talking about each and every object
over there let's go with a return
then let's set up a cart item we do need
to pass in the key since this is react
and i already know that there is a
an id property now if you don't believe
me you can navigate over here and you'll
clearly see that so each and every item
has that id property so let's say here
dot id
and then i want to use the spread
operator dot dot and then pass in rest
of the properties let's save it
so since we have four items we have four
card items on the screen
and then right after this one right
after this div let's set up a footer
and this is where we'll display the card
total as well as the clear button card
which eventually will invoke the model
and clear the card
so i'm gonna go with a horizontal line
here
then let's add heading two
with some data so total
span
and set of this one i want to set up a
dollar sign i'll say total yes
the moment it is going to be zero
don't worry about it and i say not
actually messed it up over here it
should be div with a class of card total
my apologies
that's why the css is not correct
and
after that we want to go with that clear
card button so still within the footer
we want to go with button let's add a
class right away so btn
clear btn
and let's say clear
card
let's save this let's refresh so we
don't have any errors
and this is what we should
see
on the screen where again
we used use selector
to access our entire store
more specifically we looked for cart
which represents that initial state in
the initial state we have all these
values so we're able to structure and
then we check for the amount
if it's less than one we display the
message
if we have some items in there then we
just iterate over them and for every
item we return that card item and then
below that we have total which at the
moment is zero eventually this will be
dynamic as well as the clear card button
which eventually will remove all the
items from the cart awesome and up next
i wanna set up the cart item
where we're passing in all of the data
from the cart items so we go here with
dot dot an item basically
we spread out all the properties so we
can access them
of course here when we destructure the
props
and then we just want to set up some
return with the image title and rest of
the stuff yes of course
none of the buttons at the moment will
work but at least we'll have a better
looking card item and also we want to
get two icons from the icons we want to
get rest of them the chevron down and
chevron up
so i'm gonna navigate to the card item
first let me grab both of them let me
get the import then we're looking for
chevron down
and chevron
chevron up
after that we want to go in the
structure all the props so we're looking
for id
image title
price
as well as the amount and as far as the
return let's start over here with simple
article
so we want to go here with
article and then let's add a class of
cart
item
then we want to go with
image and source will be the image
so let me say here dynamically image and
as far as the alternative well we have
the title for that so let's save it and
we should see the images and if we do
and of course we can proceed to the next
step
after that we want to set up a div
heading 4
is where we'll display the title so
let's save that
then we also want to set up the price
so let's say here heading 4 with the
class of item
price which comes with a little bit of
styling and then i'll add the dollar
sign and i'll say price let's say that
then we want to set up the button
so right below we'll go with button
then class and remove
hyphen began
and we'll say remove let's say that and
then we just want to set up
those buttons to increase
or decrease the amount so we want to do
that right after this div
so this is where we
set up the heading force and button but
after that we want to go with another
div there's going to be no class
but we want to set up a button
let's call this amount
hyphen btn
and then let's add that icon over here
so in this case i want to go with
chevron up let's close it okay good
then we want to copy and paste and set
up the show rundown
so
the class is going to be the same
amount button in here we just want to
say show rundown and in between them
this is where we'll place the amount so
let's say here paragraph class name
amount and we want to render the amount
so say
mount over here let's save that and for
all of them we have one
of course in the following videos we'll
set up the functionality that
allows us to change that
and with this in place now we can start
slowly
adding our first reducers
okay so how we can set up the
functionality with redux toolkit so if
you remember previously we need to set
up the action we need to dispatch and
then we always always needed to return
a new state
and then just of course copy the values
and all that now this is not the case
with
redux token in fact it's much much much
easier
and the way we can do that we simply go
with a reducers property in the slice
and again key value pair
so my case i'm going to call this clear
card that's going to be the name of my
reducer over here now as a parameter
this function gets a state
and notice how we don't have to return
anything i don't have to return the new
state and always
avoid the mutation
basically remember with user reducer we
always always always needed to return a
new state we don't have to do that right
now why because when we installed redux
toolkit we also installed immer library
which behind the scenes does all the
heavy lifting
so in our case we can
modify the state or mutate the state
directly and yes you're not
hallucinating this is clearly the code
that mutates the state
the reason we can write such code
is because redux toolkit comes with
immer library now it's also really cool
that
if we take a look at cart slice
something that we're logging right now
in the card slice.js we have actions
and the moment we create that reducer
we'll be able to see the action created
by the name of yes exactly the same
clear card
and what that means is that we don't
need this code again remember with user
reducer we set up the action we set it
equal to string and we didn't set up the
action creator per se when we used user
reducer
but the idea would be that we actually
set up a function that returns that type
so we don't need to run around with this
variable basically have right away
function and
optionally we can also pass in the
payload
now why am i saying this because now we
can
directly use this clear cart we don't
need to set up the variable we don't
need to create the function
essentially
it's already provided for us
and then in order to invoke it
we need to get another hook from the
reactor redux and this is
use dispatch
so remember
with user reducer we use this patch in
this case we right away get it if we
invoke use dispatch
and then we
invoke dispatch so whatever we're
getting back from here and we just pass
in action creator so yes we do need to
import clear cart that's where we're
exporting over here notice export cons
and then named import or i'm sorry named
export
and then we just need to use it
and don't worry if some of this seems
confusing at this point
it will make total sense
once we complete the entire setup so
first i want to navigate to cart slice
and like i said we want to start over
here
by setting up that reducer the one that
is going to clear the e-card so let's go
here with reducers
and it's going to be an object inside of
it we just need to come up with name for
our reducer
okay so it's going to be clear card it's
going to be a function that gets the
access to the state
now
also we'll have access to the payload
basically
let's say we want to pass in the id
something we'll do a little bit later
which is going to be a second parameter
for now we don't need to worry about it
i'll set it up as a arrow function and
like i said
i know i keep repeating this but we can
mutate the state directly because behind
the scenes emer takes care of that so we
can go here with state then what is the
value here it is card items what do i
want to do i want to set it equal to an
empty array that's it that's all i want
to do and now let's go to the cart slice
let's uncomment the log
and we'll see in the console that yes we
have name and all that but now in the
actions we have a function
we have action creator by the name of
clearcard and again the beauty in this
is
the fact that we don't need to set up
anything manually as far as the action
as far as the action created we right
away get it by default
and the only thing we want to do
is pass in
the clear card function
into whatever we're getting back from
dispatch so use dispatch and then pass
it in so let's go back to the slice and
instead of logging which as i said i'll
comment this out we want to go with
export const so all these will be named
and yes we'll add more functions of
course over here
and let's go with clear cart and now
where are we looking
we're looking in the cart slash dot
actions so let's set it equal to
cart slice dot and actions so from that
object we export this and now we just
need to decide well in which component
we're going to use it
of course in our case that will be cart
container yes eventually we'll set up
the model
so we will move that functionality from
the cart container to the modal
but for now
let's just
see how we can invoke it in here so
let's say use
this patch that's the first one then
comma
and
below or above it doesn't really matter
we want to go with that
huge dispatch
so const this is going to be equal to
this patch whatever we get back use
dispatch invoke we don't need to pass
anything in
then let's keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling this is where we have our
button
and now we do want to pass in the arrow
function because of course i don't want
to invoke this immediately i only want
to invoke it when we click on a button
so let's say here
on click
then let's pass in the arrow function
and we'll say that every time we'll
click on a button we'll dispatch
an action
and in here let's pass in that
clear card again
the beauty here is that we don't need to
do all of that manual labor
we just pass in the function that
i know that i didn't import so let me go
back we want to go with clear card which
is coming from the cart slice now let me
save it and in here it says unknown
event handler because i probably did
some oh yeah this is not right
and once we click
this is what we'll see now we're not
displaying this one the condition simply
because we're not controlling the amount
yet don't worry all of that is coming up
for 10b we are just displaying the
heading 2 with your back here
and the total basically since we removed
all of the items since it's set equal to
an empty array we just have the your
back and the total
and with this in place
now we can set up rest of the reducers
and while we're still on a topic of
state management
in the redux toolkit reducers
let's also cover
an alternative option
and that is simply the fact that we can
return a new state
from the reducer so let me comment this
one out let me type here return but we
need to be aware of the major gotcha and
that is following
whatever we will return
from reducer as our new state will
become the new state
so let's say if i'm going to return a an
empty object yes our state will
immediately turn into an empty object
without any of these properties same
works if i'm going to return here empty
array
so let's say if i return an object and
if i just say cart items equals to an
empty array yes i will update
this property
but automatically i'll remove these ones
just to showcase that let me save it
let me click on clear card and you'll
notice
that now
i have nothing here as far as the amount
as well as the total and i can clearly
see that if i navigate to the devtools
so let me
open up the redux devtools on the small
browser window and then when it comes to
our state notice
all the properties are missing now only
the cart items is there
so let me comment this one out and let's
take a look at the use case where
this is going to come in handy
so in one of our upcoming
projects we'll have some pages and in
there we'll have a bunch of inputs that
are going to be our state values
and essentially there's also going to be
a clear button
and the idea is like this once the user
starts typing something let's say
changes some values around here
at some point maybe he or she wants to
clear out all the input values
so in that case we're gonna take that
initial state
and we'll just return that from our
reducer so let's say you set up here
state with whatever default values
and then
when you have the reducer
that just sets it back to default you
just pass that initial state as a return
in your reducer so that's one of the use
cases where this comes in handy but we
do need to be careful again whatever
we're going to return from the reducer
will become
that new state value so if
we omit some of the properties yes they
will be excluded okay and once we can
clear the cart
it's a smooth sailing from here
we just want to set up those functions
we want to add the functionality and yes
we will take a look at the action well
it looks like and why we're looking for
the payload
and i know i said this already a million
different times but
since right now we can modify the state
directly
there's tons of ways how you can set
this up now i purposely kind of
tried to
showcase the mutation approach where yes
of course
in these examples for increase and
decrease
we can return
a new array
but i purposely just found the exact
item and then updated the amount plus or
minus and also of course you can combine
increase and decrease into one function
let's say you can call this toggle
and
of course you'll just have to provide
here more values whether you're
increasing decryption that could be your
challenge
for now we just want to focus on a
remove
item and the first thing that i want to
showcase is the fact that we can access
the payload so whatever we pass in
because in order
to
get the specific item in order to remove
it i do need to get the id
correct and if you were paying attention
in the card item we did the structure id
however
we haven't used it here
so this is something that we will pass
into the function
and essentially as far as the remove
item i'll get it from action.payload
because that is a structure i'll name
this item id
and then i just want to set equal state
card items to the new array now i wasn't
doing this purposely again there's tons
of ways how you can set it up but in my
case i just thought that filter is the
fastest one so we go to state
dot card items we filter it we look for
specific item
that does not
match daddy and we return that into
discard items so if the id matches
so whatever we pass in matches to the 80
then that item won't get returned and in
the process we'll move it from this
array
so let's try this one out where in the
cart slice
let's set up that remove item
so i'm going to go here with remove item
and first
i just want to showcase
how we can access the payload so first
one is the state so we access the state
here
then i'm going to go with action and
later i'll showcase how we can structure
that and for time being let's just look
for the action and now let's think about
it where do we want to access
all these functions they remove items
increase decrease
and not calculate totals so only these
three
well we want to get that in the car item
so first in the cart slice we want to
export that again what's really cool is
the fact that the name is exactly the
same we don't really need to think about
it and as i said it shouldn't be remove
items it should be remove item i
apologize for some reason i just keep
adding those ss there
then
let's navigate to the card item
first we want to import
the
remove item so we're looking for remove
item
and notice how right away we get that
named import and also we want to get
that dispatch
so
let's just set it up over here where
i'll say import
then use dispatch that is coming from
react redux
then
the very top we're going to go here with
const
dispatch
and that will be equal to use dispatch
let's invoke it and then let's look for
that remove button
so now basically
every time we'll click on a button
we will remove that specific item so
let's say here on click
again we do want to pass in the arrow
function first and then let's say
dispatch
and we'll go with a remove item and now
let's pass in the id
so first thing which you'll see once you
click
is the log in the console so let's click
and check it out
in here we see two things
first we see type
so notice how that is right away already
set up for us like i said we don't need
to do anything right away it has cart
and then remove item so this is the
action that we're dispatching and we
also get the payload now can you pass in
the payload as an object absolutely but
if we pass in as a symbol property
then we have
payload is equal to whatever
so
knowing this we can set up rest of the
functionality
where in the cart slice
i'll assign
action.payload equal to an id
const
and i think i'm going to call this
product id or sorry now i'll call this
item id so const
item
id is equal to
action
payload
and then
let's
set up the new value for the state card
items
state again yes we're modifying this
we're going to go with cart items is
equal to and now let's access the old
value basically before the update we can
do that with state card items then let's
run filter and like i said
if the id matches
the
item won't be returned
so essentially we'll remove it from our
cart items array i'm going to call this
items
and i'm going to go with implicit return
where i'm going to say
if item id does not match the item id
only then return it from the array
and as a result check it out
click
and we just keep removing the items from
our bag again yes we're not affecting
the amount as well as the total all of
that is coming up but we should be able
to remove all of the items from our cart
be it with clear cart
or
individually by clicking on the remove
button all right and now once we're
familiar now we can remove item let's
also do the same thing with increase and
decrease now in order to make things
interesting i already destructure the
payload so remember we're getting the
action object and we're looking for the
payload so in this case i just
destructure that in the case of increase
we go to state card items find so we get
that specific item in this case where
the id matches unlike the filter
approach
and then i just want to update the
amount so every time i'll click
on the increase button will increase the
amount of specific items we have in the
cart for this phone or that phone
and hopefully you see where i'm going
with this and eventually of course this
will also affect the amount as well as
the total and yes i'll set them up
pretty much right away
since the functionality is exactly the
same apart from the fact that in this
case we increase and in this case we
decrease and like i said if you want to
challenge yourself set up a toggle
functionality
where you look for one more value
increase or decrease which of course is
going to be in the payload and then
depending on that set up the
functionality but for now let's just
worry about these two
so we're gonna navigate to cart
slash and then right after remove item
let's say here increase
we'll set up our function
let's say state like i said right away
look for the payload
set it equal to
and when it comes to functionality we
want to go with const first we want to
get that cart
item
the specific one where the id matches
and we can do that with state
cart items dot find
then let's pass in the callback function
let's say item and then item id
is equal to payload and we'll pass this
in as an object so it's going to be
payload
dot id
and then
let's increase that amount
so now i'm accessing that one specific
card item
i have the amount property and please
don't confuse this with the total amount
so that's the total with all of the
items that we have in the cart
when we're talking about this cart item
amount property we're talking about this
one over here
for that specific card item
and we'll just say
car item
amount
so whatever it is right now
plus or yeah in this case
plus one
and then
in order to
set up decrease
you want to copy and paste
you want to go with
decrease still going to be a payload
okay all of that is awesome we'll still
look for the card item
the difference here is minus one
and then we want to add them of course
to our exports
so let's say
increase
decrease and we want to navigate to the
card
item
we want to import the other two as well
so we're going to go here with increase
then they crease
both of them and first let's set up the
increase because for a decrease we'll
have to add a little bit more
functionality
so let's go with mount button let's say
on click we already have the dispatch so
we don't need to worry about that one
and we just want to pass in the increase
so we're going to go here with
dispatch
and then inside of this patch let's pass
in the increase and like i said in order
to make this interesting i'm gonna go
with
an id
now normally if you're setting this up
as an object of course you'll pass in
more properties
but in this case i won't do that
and for some reason oh yeah my bad so i
set up the importer in the wrong place
let me add a comma here
and hopefully everything is going to
work yep looks about right
and if we try this out notice how again
we're changing this value over here for
each item and again the functionality
here
is following where we look for the
payload which in this case is an object
that's why we go here with payload dot
id just to showcase that we can pass in
more data and then we just increase the
amount and the same thing we can do with
decrease so let's go back to the card
item
i'll take this entire thing for the on
click
or copy and paste
and now let's go
with decrease instead so say decrease
again we're passing the id that doesn't
change it's refreshed so we start from
the scratch and now notice how we can
decrease the amount now the problem is
that we're going negative
so i think it's going to make a bit more
sense
if we'll check
for the amount and again we're talking
about the amount of specific item not
overall amount and if it is equal to one
we want to remove it since that way
we'll have zero items in the cart
and if it's bigger than one then of
course we just want to run the decrease
so i'm going to go back to this on click
and we'll set up if
amount is equal to one that means that
we're pressing the button amount is
already equal to one and if that is the
case well we might as well remove the
item from the cart correct we'll say
remove item and we'll just pass in the
id now we do want to pass the return
right after because you don't want to
continue reading the code
and if the amount is bigger than one
then of course we
just decrease the amount so let me go
here let me refresh and notice i can
increase
i can naturally decrease so all of that
is working but the moment i get
the amount of one
if i will click the decrease i'll
automatically remove the item from the
cart
all right and up next let's take a look
at how we can
calculate the totals because at the
moment yes
we can nicely control our cart
but that is not affecting the amount
that we have all the way at the top and
also it's not affecting the total
and in order to fix that we'll come up
with new reducer i'll call this
calculate totals and i went with this
functionality
so
i created new variables amount and total
then i iterate over the current
card items and each of them has the
amount property
so i just add to the overall amount one
so the one that represents the entire
card and the same goes for a total only
in this case i multiply
the amount of items i have
with the price and that is equal to the
total one so i set up the loop
i add
both of these values and at the very end
i just go with state amount is equal to
amount so whatever we created over here
the same goes for total now where do we
want to invoke that well that's a good
question let's keep on scrolling in the
readme and
i actually set this one up in the app
so in the app
i will set up a use effect
and that user effect will depend on the
card items so use your selector grab the
card items from the card and then every
time
there's going to be some change in the
card items will dispatch the calculate
totals and as a result
both of those values will change
in here
as well as in the total
so let's try to set this one up and
let's start by creating the function
calculate and then
totals
again it's going to be our function
we'll access the state as far as the
logic let's go with
let amount
is equal to zero and let's say not i
have a tiny bug over here then i want to
copy and paste and let's just say total
so by default it's always going to be
zero and 0.
then we want to go with state
then cart items
let's
iterate over so call this for each
and then we'll access each and every
item and each and every item has the
amount and total property and we just
want to add this to the total amount
therefore we'll go with plus equals and
then
item and amount
now when it comes to the amount of money
we want to multiply
the price
that each item has
with the amount of items we have in a
card so total is equal to
and now in this case we'll go with
plus equals
item
amount
multiplied by item dot price and once we
have this one in place
up next
we want to set state
amount
equals to amount that we just set up
and the same goes with total
so let's go here
let's say total is equal to total
and after that we want to export that so
let's say calculate totals
and we just need to set it up in the
app.js
so let's navigate to app.js
and in here
let's grab first the use selector and
use dispatch we'll need both of them
so let's say import
use dispatch use selector
and we'll set it equal to from react
redux and also i want to get that
calculate totals
so let's say calculate totals that is
coming from the features okay
beautiful and as far as the logic well
first let's grab the card items and we
use use selector for that so cart
items now that is equal to use selector
let's pass in the function and let's say
here store
is equal to store cart and i'm not going
to repeat myself how we can access that
and also
we want to set up that dispatch so const
dispatch
and that is equal to use dispatch let's
invoke that
and let's finally set up that
use effect so let's say here use effect
and then as far as the callback function
will invoke this every time there's a
change to the cart items so every time
we'll update something
related to the card items we will invoke
this use effect specifically we want to
go dispatch and we want to pass in
calculate totals
so check it
out now we still have four here but i
can clearly see my total
and what's going to happen every time
we'll click
on any of the buttons and all that will
nicely display whatever items we have in
the cart now there's tiny bug over here
basically we need to set this one to
fixed
essentially how many
uh numbers after that and don't worry
we'll do that in a second but the goal
here
is that now
every time we remove item from the cart
or we clear the cart all together
it will affect the amount of items we
have
which we display over here
and also the total
now in order to fix
the bug there with too many numbers we
just need to go to
cart container
and where we have the total let's go
with two fixed
so that's again the javascript method
that we have access to and we'll say
that we only want
two numbers after the dot so now
everything is going to work
and just like that we have calculate
totals in place and every time we'll
make some changes to our cart
they
will affect our initial state in the
card slash all right and up next i want
to set up a modal and in a process we'll
create another slash
and we'll see how we can
access data when we have multiple
reducers in our store
and the first step is going to be
creating a modal
js
with the following code
and then we want to import that in the
app.js and place it above the navbar so
i'm going to start working on that where
first i'm going to create model js
not going to set up any kind of imports
in this case
we haven't set up the slides yet so
let's just create that component
and as far as the return
we want to go here
with a side
and we want to add a class name of modal
container and as i said if you're
interested in the css just please look
for those classes
in the index.css then we want to create
a div with a class of modal
inside of it let's say heading 4 with
the text of remove all items from your
shopping cart and after that we want to
go with button container where basically
we'll place two buttons just to showcase
how it's going to look like
let me go to complete one
and again we'll display that once we try
to clear the clark
so this is going to be the result so
right after the heading we're going to
go
with div with the class of
btn
container inside of it let's place two
buttons
first one will be
confirm one and the second one will be
the clear one type for both of them will
be button and class name btn and i'll
call this confirm btn and as far as the
text
i'm going to go with confirm as well and
the same deal with the clear one we just
want to change some values around where
it's not going to be
confirmed it's going to be cancel
instead
and instead of confirm hyphen btn we're
going to go with
clear ptn now we want to go to app.js
we want to get this particular component
so
i mean let me try here with the auto
import let's see we have model yup
that worked and once we save
check it out this is going to be our
model so we have the component now we
just need to set up the logic all right
up next let's set up the slice for the
model
so remember
we have features folder
for time being we only have one feature
we have the card
but now i want to add the moto feature
which is going to be located in the
modal slice and then we want to set up
the functionality where again we're
going to go with create slash
we want to set up some initial state in
this case it's going to be
is open
and i'll set it equal to false
then we want to go with model slice come
up with name in the show state and right
away let's set up those two reducers
we're going to go with open modal
and close model we want to export that
and we also want to export
modal slice reducer and in the store we
want to set up another key
only in this case is going to be equal
to this modal slice reducer
as a result we'll be able to access the
state as well as the reducers
all over our application and the first
thing that we'll do
is in the app.js we'll grab is open
and we'll display this one conditionally
so i'm gonna go to the features we want
to create a new folder let's call this
modal
then we want to go new file and we'll
call this
modal
slice
js and then inside of it
we first want to grab the create slash
so let's go here with create and let's
see whether yep gives me the import then
we want to
set up the initial state in my case just
going to be one property again this is
just to practice
working with more realistic application
where of course there's going to be more
features
so we're going to go here is open and by
default let's set it equal to false
false and then let's set up that slice
so const modal
slice is equal to create slice let's
pass in the object name modal
then initial state is equal to initial
state let's right away set up those
reducers
now what reduces we're going to have
we're going to have open
modal reducer which is going to be equal
to state
and action
again we're just practicing as far as
the action we're not going to use it
and in here let's just say state
is open so if i want to open a model
what is going to be value well
might as well set it equal to true kind
of makes sense don't you think
then let's copy and paste and now we
want to close the model now what is
going to be the value for is open well
let's set it back to false
then we want to export
three things the main reducer and i'm
not going to log it we already have done
that so
export default now of course we have
different object
but the property we want to export
meaning the
method is still the same we want to
export the reducer that's number one and
then remember those action creators so
we're going to go here with export cons
and now we're looking for open modal
close model and both of them are coming
from modal slice
and the actions now
in order for everything to work we
definitely definitely definitely need to
go to store
so let's find where is that sucker
over here and then in the store now we
want to get the modal slice
so i have to change some things around
this is going to be coming from the
modal
name will also be modal this is going to
be a
modal reducer
and yes of course the property i'm going
to go with modal as well so model will
be equal to
modal reducer
so that's good
now let's try it out in our application
on a big screen
and
at the moment we're calculating the
totals notice
we have already two actions not only the
init and we also run calculate totals
what i want to showcase though is that
instead of just cart now we also have
the modal
and now let's utilize that where in the
app js
not only i want to get the modal
i also want to access what i want to
access is open
and i want to set this one up
conditionally since in a second we'll
add all the functionality so in here
remember we were accessing the cart
so the only difference is that now i
want to access the modal and i'll say is
open
is
open and that will be equal not to the
store cart
i'll say
store
model
and where i have the model
i'll have
the conditional rendering where i'll say
is open if it's true only then
display the model so let's move it in
and since the value is false
we don't display the model now if i'll
manually go back to model slice and i'll
say that the value is true
i mean
you're not going to be surprised
probably by the fact that we display the
model okay awesome
so now let's add that functionality
where
instead of just clearing the cart
why don't we open up the modal when we
click on this button
and then once we get to the modal
container then we'll decide do we really
want to
remove all the contents
and then close the model or we simply
want to close the model so first let's
start in the cart container and as i
said not yes
you'll find all of the logic here in the
readme where first in the cart container
we want to get the open model from the
model slice
and instead of clearing the cart
directly we'll go dispatch and open
model
and from there we'll
finish everything in the model address
so let's start in the cart container
so we have all of these imports okay
that's awesome
but we want to copy and paste
and we want to get
open modal
from the modal slice
open modal and instead of card slash
we're going to go here with modal and
then modal slice
then let's keep on moving
i don't think we actually need this
import anymore
so we can remove it
and then where we have the clear cart
now let's pass in the open modal
same deal we invoke it so that doesn't
change now the difference of course is
going to be that now once we click on
clearing cart we display the model so
now let's navigate there and let's
handle that
so
what first do we need over there well
we'll need quite a few things
first we want to get the closed model
because regardless on which button we
click i want to clear it i want to get
the use dispatch i'll need it since i
want to
invoke some reducers and i also want to
get the clear card so notice how again
we're getting this data
from
multiple
slices model slice and card slice
and then of course we'll just set up the
functionality so
let's go back over here let's set up
all those three imports
we're gonna get the close model
close modal and i also want to get
the clear card
clear card
and also we want to get the use dispatch
so let's see where that is going to work
so use
this patch yep i have all of them so now
i can remove these suckers
then we want to quickly
set up the dispatch
where effectively we just go with use
dispatch and we invoke it
and now let's set up the functionality
where if we click on confirm i want to
do two things
not only i want to clear the card but i
also want to close the model now if we
go with cancel then we'll just close the
modal so let's go here with button we're
going to go with on click
and then in here let's pass in the
function
and then
we're not going to pass in any kind of
argument we'll just go with this patch
then clear
cart
that's the first thing we want to invoke
and then the second one it looks like i
have some weird bug oh yeah over here
and the second thing
is the closed model
so let's pass this one in and i know i
keep repeating this but i really like
the fact that we don't need to do any of
that
manual labor where we need to set up the
actions and all that in this case we
simply right away get those functions
and we pass in the dispatch which
obviously is way less time consuming and
also less chance for errors
so let's do the same thing with this
button
and the only thing we want to change
here is clearcard where we basically
want to remove it so if we confirm
then our cart is empty if however we
just click on cancel
we close out the model so that's how we
can add another feature to our
application all right and now let's see
how we can set up a synchronous
functionality with a redux toolkit
so here's the plan
so i have
quarters api
basically an api
that serves some json data just so we
can practice on fetching
data and in the user reducer project we
already work with this url
so it's course api and then react use
reducer card project which essentially
returns the same data that we currently
have
in the card items so use this url to
fetch data when initially our
application loads
and here's the thing we cannot just
simply set this up
in our current reducers it's not going
to work that's why with
redux toolkit we install another library
the thunk one
and
from the redux toolkit we get this
create
async
thunk
and we right away wanna invoke it
and the result we want to export
so this is something that will require
directly in our components so it's very
similar to
how we exported
the action creators
from the reducers however in this case
we export this directly in my case i'm
going to call this get cart items so we
invoke create async thunk
and it's looking for two things
for the action type so essentially in
here we just come up with a name
of our action and second is going to be
that callback function
now in the following video i'll show you
more options but
at the very least we pass here this
function and this function needs to
return a promise
i'm just using fetch to fetch data and
remember
when we go with fetch.then
we return basically a success response
and with catch of course that's going to
be the error but regardless from this
function
we are automatically returning the
promise this is what the callback
function is looking for it's looking
for that promise
and of course you're not limited to the
just fetch
you can set up all kinds of things in
here but just remember that this
function needs to return a promise so of
course if you just stick async in front
of it
then by default it's going to return
promise which is something that we'll
take a look at in the next video
and then in the fetch i want to pass in
the url
so the one that gets me the product
and
when it comes to this callback function
it returns a life cycle actions
so if you remember when we work with
promises we add few options
promise
could be pending
it can be fulfilled and rejected
so where we have the create slice
what we want to do is set up extra
reducers property it's going to be an
object and then in order to access those
lifecycle actions the syntax is like
this where we go with name what we're
getting back
and then dot pending fulfilled and
rejected and yes
these need to match to the t
because
they are provided
by the redux toolkit and then we want to
enclose this
with the square brackets
and then we'll set this equal to a
function
so what do we want to do when we're
pending basically when we're loading and
that's why we have the state value is
loading and we'll set it equal to true
then what we want to do if we're
successful and this is the case where
the data that we're returning
in the case of success in our case
response.json is going to be located in
the action payload then of course we'll
log it just so you can see so once we
have successfully data we want to set
is loading to false and card items to
the actual payload
and if there's some kind of error we
have rejected option
and in that case for this application we
just want to set is loading to false
and also keep in mind that when it comes
to fetch
404 is not an error
so we'll only have this one if there's
some kind of network error and at the
very last we want to grab get card items
in the app app component and then when
our application loads we want to do two
things we want to dispatch get card
items so the asynchronous function
and then we also want to grab is loading
from the state and while we're loading
we'll display this
and once we're successful we'll set the
state card items equal
to the data that we're getting back
so let's try this one out where i'm
going to go to cart slice
and first i want to grab that create a
sync thunk so that one is coming from
redux toolkit then i want to set up the
url so right after the import let's go
here with const url
and you have two options you can either
get it from readme or you can just
navigate here in the browser so since i
already have it open in a browser
i'll use this approach so again this is
the url where we can fetch those
products just like we have in the card
items
and then let's keep on scrolling and
we'll go with
create a sync thunk and we'll set it
equal to our function but we want to
write away exporters so let's say const
get
card
items and that is equal to
create a sync thunk and like i said it's
looking for two things
the type so in here we just need to come
up with a name in my case i'm going to
go with cart forward slash get
card item so that's going to be my
action and second will be that callback
function
and here let's right away go with
returned fetch let's pass in the url
then dot then so if we're successful i
want to turn this into a json so say
response response json let's invoke that
and then let's also go with catch and
don't worry in next video we'll take a
look at more reasonable approach how to
handle this but for time being i just
want to get that data from the url so
let's go here with error and then
log that
sucker and once we are done
we want to keep on scrolling
and in the create slice right after
reducers the property name
is extra reducer so notice we right away
get that suggestion and like i said then
we get those
life cycle actions
so for every function that we will
create
in this case it is get card items we'll
get those three life cycle actions
pending fulfilled and rejected and the
way we can access that we go with the
same name so get card items in this case
and then notice we right away have those
options fulfilled pending and rejected
so in my case i'm going to start with
pending that is while we're still
loading and in this function
same way we can access the state and
also we can get the action so action is
going to be useful once we get the data
for now while we're pending we just want
to grab the state and i want to set the
state is loading value equal to what
equal to true correct so while we're
loading
his loading will be equal to
true
then we want to copy and paste like so
we just want to add the commas so
there's no bugs in here and we want to
change these ones around but instead of
pending
now i'm looking for fulfilled
and in this case i do want to add
another parameter which is going to be
action and again this action will
contain
the result
if we're successful so in this case if
we're successful we return the json
response
and what i'm going to do is set my
cart item so state
and then cart
items equal to what action and payload
and yes let's also log it just so you
can see where it's coming from but i can
tell you right away that there's a
payload property and that's the one that
holds those cart items so let's log the
action and lastly
we also have rejected
and like i said since we're using fetch
it's only for network errors
and for time being we'll set this equal
to false and also
there's a tiny issue here
once we have the data of course the
loading will be false
so
we don't need to export this we're
actually in good shape we already export
that function
here with export now we just want to go
to
app.js we want to grab the function get
cart items we want to invoke it
once our application loads and we also
want to check for each loading
so let's navigate to app.js
and since we already import
the calculate totals from the card slice
simply want to add a comma and we'll go
with get card items
and then let's keep on moving not only i
want to get the card items i also want
to check for ears loading
so if we're loading then we'll display
different return and then let's set up a
different use effect
where i'm going to go with use effect
and i'll invoke it
only when my application loads
so once my application loads whatever i
want to do i want to dispatch and we'll
go with get
card items and we'll invoke it let's
also set up that return
where basically
if we're loading
this is what we want to return we want
to go with dave with class of loading
and then heading one loading so let's
set it up here if is loading
is true
then we want to go with return
then let's set up the div here let's add
a class of loading
and then inside of it we're going to go
with heading 1 and
loading dot dot and once we say for
second we'll notice that loading and
then we get the product and if you don't
believe me
let's navigate to the big screen over
here
let's refresh
and then let's check it out
in here we have the pending which is
going to be for that loading one and we
can clearly see our state
so notice how awesome it is in the redux
devtools where you can clearly see your
actions
so what actions we're dispatching and
what is the state at that time and we
can even see the difference
so basically if i'm going to go here
with fulfilled notice this is going to
be the difference so in the cart
we basically get this is loading and we
set it equal to false and also in the
console you can see what we're getting
back
remember i said that once we log over
here in the cart slash
we are logging the action
so what is
in this action it is a payload
and that's the data that we're getting
back so we have this array of four items
we set
here
state card items equal
to the payload so again something we can
definitely double check over here so if
i go here with state
notice with fulfilled for example this
is going to get me those car items those
four card items and one more thing that
we can actually do is go back to the
cart slice
and set this equal to an empty array
so the card atoms and that way you'll
clearly see how we can
change this once
the data gets here asynchronously so
let's navigate back again let's refresh
just so we're on the safe side and if we
go right now with
action fulfilled and if we take a look
at the difference now i'll notice two
things first of all is loading changed
from true to false
and also notice how we switch the card
items so initially it was empty array
and now essentially we get those four
items and again all of our functionality
still works we can clearly see that
in our actions over here
but now we're getting this data
asynchronously once our application
all right and lastly i just want to
showcase
what options we have
with the callback function because in
our previous example we just looked at
the most basic setup
so now let's go over the more complex
one and don't worry in this video you
don't have to type along and in fact we
won't use
any of this extra data in our current
application the goal is to simply get
the gears in your head turning
and showcase large amount of options we
have and first what i want to do is
install another library the http library
by the name of axios because i do want
to showcase
how essentially
we can return
a value for the error and since fetch is
not responding to 404 basically for
fetch the 404 errors are not errors i
actually want to use the axios instead
again if you don't want to do that you
can just sit back and relax
where i'm going to go with npm install
axios first
then we definitely want to spin up the
dev server of course so npm start let me
close this one then we want to navigate
to cart slice i think i can remove the
items we won't need it anymore so axios
from axios
let's keep on moving
and before we do anything
like i said we can create this function
right away as a sync
which essentially just means that we'll
right away return a promise correct so
go here with sync and that also means
that we can await so we can set up more
logic so let me remove all of this code
here
and let's just go with try and catch
right away since we can also do that
and then let's wait for that response so
i'm going to say here const
and then response is equal to await now
i'm going to go with axios and then i'll
pass in the url and if we're successful
whatever we want to do we want to return
that response again keep in mind we are
returning a promise and yes we're
handling that in the x reducers so none
of this functionality changes right now
we're just
switching right now
our create a sync thunk callback
function to a sync where we're using
axios now once we save we will get some
errors in console don't worry about it
the reason for that is because when it
comes to axios
the data is located in the data property
and just to showcase that let me go here
with log and then response
and you'll see in a console
if you scroll up you'll notice over here
this is what we're getting back
and essentially what we want to do we
want to pass in this data property
down to these life cycle actions
so we're talking about this one over
here so let's scroll up
and we'll go here with return
and let's go with response and then data
again
this is just because that's how the
response is structured so once we save
notice how everything worked correctly
where again we're getting those items
and if we take a look at the action it's
still the same thing we're getting this
payload
and the payload is that array
so that's the first thing that i want to
mention
also well we can pass here the argument
now what does that mean well in our case
we're not going to use that but we need
to imagine that let's say we're going to
be setting up
some kind of functionality and we do
want to pass here
the value let's say whether that is a
user or some kind of parameter or
something so in this case i'm just going
to say random
and if we want to access that again in
our case it's not going to change
anything but if we want to access that
this is going to be the first parameter
so in my case i'm going to go with name
and let's simply log that and we'll
clearly see
that we can access that value again
not something we'll use in our
application but it's very very important
because there's going to be applications
where of course this is going to be
important the fact that we can pass
something here from our component and we
can access it
in our create async thunk so that's the
first thing that i want to mention now
second we also have access to
thunk api again you can name it
differently but i mean common convention
is calling this thunk api which gives us
even more options now what am i talking
about well first of all let's log
something let's go with log then let's
access thunk api and you know what let's
just lock the entire thing
so
you know what there's
quite a few things here in the console
so let me remove this action basically
i'll come in this one out for your
reference
and also hopefully it's clear how we can
pass
the parameters from the components so
that's clear
but then check it out we have this
somewhat giant object with bunch of
useful things
so
here's the thing we could
get the state
now what's interesting we're getting the
state of the entire application
and
this should get the wheels turning in
your head
because that means that we can get any
values from the rest of the features so
let me quickly quickly showcase that so
i'm going to go with log and then thunk
api
and then let's go with get state and
let's invoke it and in the console i
have both
i have the values
for a card as well as the model so
imagine if you have for example a user
feature
where you're setting up the user yes
when you're setting up your async action
you can actually access it
so i can set up the user in a different
feature
and i can still access it with the help
of this tank api which is very very very
powerful
and also what's interesting well we can
dispatch
if we take a look at the object over
here
notice we have this dispatch option
so what we can dispatch well for example
let's open up the modal while we're
fetching so let's try this one out we're
right after the get state and all that
let me go here
and we're going to go with thunk api
we're going to go with dispatch and now
we want to pass in
open
and modal
again
something that is not even in our slice
and check it out and as i said i forgot
to add here
the parentheses notice
even though this reducer is not even in
this feature
we can still access it with thunk api
and i know you're sick of hearing this
but this is extremely powerful
because we can do all kinds of
functionality in the create async thunk
and lastly what i want to showcase
is how we can return a
specific response because at the moment
yes we have catch and we are basically
getting the error but normally from the
api
you'll get some kind of specific message
so first of all how we can pass this
through again we're going to look for
thunk api and we want to go here with
the return first of all and then the
property or the method you're looking
for so let's go here with
thunk api
is
reject with value
so in this case i will hard code this
but keep in mind that normally with
axiorys is going to be located in error
dot response so in here let's say
something
went
wrong like so
and then let's keep on moving let's keep
on moving and where we have the rejected
now we can look for that action in our
case again we don't have any error
values in the state or nothing like that
but let's just log whether we can see
that action whether we can see that
everything works and since we're using
axiorys now i can mess up the url and
for axiorys it will be an error what
that means
well we'll trigger this and we'll
basically pass this value
down to our rejected so let's save it
and then notice in the console we right
away see this log
and we have this payload where we have
something went wrong
so for example if we're getting some
kind of error from the api it's going to
be located an error response and we can
nicely pass this down using thunk api
and then reject with the value
so that's how we can set up asynchronous
functions with redux toolkit
and this concludes our tutorial
hopefully everyone enjoyed it
and i'll see you next videos